all right here we are
uh we had a problem with the original
stream
it shut itself off after like a minute
i'm not really sure why
but uh yeah so hopefully everyone will
come over to this one
seems like it's okay and see if uh we
get [ __ ] going here let me go to the
over the other one yeah what a pain i
never had that happen before like
youtube was just like uh hey we're just
gonna shut your [ __ ] off bye
there's nobody on it yeah that's what
i'm saying
oh okay there's debra yay all right hey
all right yeah sorry about that i was
just kind of it just shut off my other
stream so i had to start another one
everybody still hung over from the show
last night
yeah it's like i did okay yeah i like i
said the the secret
is i had a friend tell me this a long
time ago who's like a real uh
who is a real heavy uh drinker and and
drug user
um told me that they're like here's
because i was like dude i was like how
do you drink so much and not
like not feel like hammered ass the next
day and he said the secret is
that before you go to bed you take three
aspirin and drink a whole bottle of
water but you have to do it before you
go to sleep
you can't wait till you get up because
then you'll be rehydrate yourself
yeah you'll be dehydrated and it's like
and you'll have a headache and it'll be
too late then but if you do it right
before you go to sleep
then you should be okay and you know
what it works
yeah i can't believe it like sometimes i
get kind of tired the rest of the the
next day but i don't
like feel crappy or have a headache or
anything like that when i get up which
is
crazy when we when we were in the army
we were real bad we would just give
ourselves iv
yeah well you're glad you could do that
[Laughter]
ah yeah can you just drunk gatorade that
seems like it would be a lot easier
the thing is it was a lot faster there's
a lot because it goes right into your
bloodstream yeah it went right into your
bloodstream it was a lot
faster because you'd have to work yeah
that's yeah
mango badger says last night's show was
a classic i didn't get to bed till 4am
yeah we had a really good time doing
that show
i knew it was going to be long because i
knew i had like a lot of topics to think
but i didn't realize that it was going
to be almost five
hours long and it didn't ridiculous it
didn't even seem like it like it didn't
seem like
it kind of seemed long to me a little
bit i guess i wasn't
like i was having a ring reading it and
you know going through it but yeah it
seemed like it was pretty long to me
yeah i was still having a good time and
i was just kind of like oh whatever holy
crap it's almost five hours like four
and a half hours long
that's [ __ ] crazy what are we even
doing
but yeah do you remember um that you
woke up in the middle of the night last
night and you opened the back
uh the sliding glass door yeah you
remember doing that yeah okay i didn't
know if you remember doing it if you
were sleeping oh no i was looking for
pookie
i know it was really like really weird
what time it was like two or three in
the morning yeah and i heard like the
sliding glass door in her bedroom open
and i'm like what are you doing like i
thought he heard a bear or something
he's like i'm looking for pookie and i'm
like pookie's on the bed
no i got up in the middle of the night
and noticed that the porch light was on
oh okay so you thought that pookie was
still out and i thought
yeah and i looked out there and [ __ ]
beigers was sitting out on the porch
looking into the [ __ ] glass
oh
[Music]
trying to make sure they were both in
but they were they were both you didn't
tell me beijing was out there
she was out because i said pookie's on
the bed because she was slept next to my
foot for some reason
that pokey back in but forgot to [ __ ]
bring fake vision
yeah so she's that's why it wasn't that
long that's why she wasn't out there for
very long though
no i don't think it might it might not
have been that late actually no it was
only like uh it's 12.
oh okay so i was like it was two but
that was like a different time so
so she'd only been out for a little
while yeah i fell asleep about
i fell asleep and about an hour later i
realized she was out okay
so she wasn't out there for long she's
stayed out all night before
yeah she gets mad you wake up in the
[ __ ] morning and she's [ __ ]
waiting at the door and you open up she
was like
man then she grabbed and she burst into
the house like
she yeah [ __ ] you never heard a cat
make that noise leaving me outside all
night god
damn it that's how she yells at me yeah
what the [ __ ]
she doesn't do anything she just sleeps
out on the porch but yeah
man man like some of the south park
she is she's like a beautiful it's like
a car like carmen
she does she makes the [ __ ] [ __ ]
noises yeah it's just kind of like
she does that she just always sounds
like she's [ __ ] all the time yeah
whereas pookie she has a thing like she
meows every now and then
or like makes a little peep kind of
noise but mostly what she does is she
whirs
and it's like she doesn't open her mouth
to do it it's almost like a purr but not
quite
it sounds like a little motor and it's
like however she does it like there's a
different inflections on it
um depending on what she wants to tell
you
like if she goes that means like come on
it's play time
yeah or sometimes if she doesn't come on
sure i think it means chase me because
she's running away
and she's doing it and like i said her
mouth doesn't open it's like it's from
her throat
and sometimes like if you kind of like
touch her like when she's not expecting
it she'll go like
yeah like stop it yeah but she's usually
making that noise and she's running to
the front door
yeah i want you to let her out wanna go
sit on the board
she's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah she's
hilarious she's a silly kitty
yeah so we didn't uh watch any new
movies lately
so i thought we would just do like a
little brief side track today just
to catch up with you guys take a [ __ ]
break from new movies man
well um there's not a lot of i mean
there's some new ones but
um a lot of them like don't really look
that good or like look
kind of like the like really bottom of
the barrel low i think yeah
[ __ ] well especially the hollywood
ones man forget hollywood
well i'm kind of talking about the indie
ones that turn up on to because i'm
trying not to
necessarily there's i have a list of
ones that i want to review that are new
but i will probably have to pay to rent
those so i was like waiting and doing
some free ones first
the hollywoods were all on hold like
[ __ ] james bond and [ __ ]
and they just they just look like [ __ ] a
lot of them there's already a lot of bad
rumors about the new [ __ ]
james bond movie that's not gonna be any
good but we'll see
because it like went back for reshoots
well yeah at least they're trying to fix
it
a lot of movies do that though yeah
especially nowadays because it's like
like i said it's a lot of money and it's
like they want to get a return on their
investment i don't know i probably won't
nowadays i don't know how this [ __ ]
that's gonna [ __ ] work that nowadays
i don't think those looking i don't
think those theaters are gonna be
open like they were you know nothing
compared to what they were years ago
yeah it's all just going to be [ __ ]
directed direct to [ __ ] streaming
did uh you're doing poop oh she's
attacking the [ __ ]
she's attacking a chair she's attacking
she's biting me
she's like why are you yelling and
growling at me i'm having a good time
because she's here
she heard me making those damn whirring
noises yeah she's like she thought it
wasn't
i thought you were calling me to come to
the kitchen she's sitting right there
watching me make those noises of hers
that you're
[ __ ] talking about
yeah she thinks everything's funny yeah
i told him i said i got a i got an email
from
chewie the other day and i was like they
got all their little
pet halloween costumes out and i'm like
i was kind of looking at him like i know
she wouldn't wear one i just had to put
her in
i'm just kind of like looking i i really
really wanted to get her a little
werewolf outfit
i mean it was like it's one of those
ones the front legs yeah it's like one
of those ones where if you look at it
from the front it looks like a tiny
little two-legged creature
yeah and it has like little little jeans
and like a little checkered shirt and
then it has this big foofy like
werewolf head and i was like imagine
like pookie's little gray face like
coming out of that [ __ ] werewolf head
i'm like that would be [ __ ] hilarious
i would just laugh and laugh and laugh
until i died
it would just be the funniest [ __ ]
thing but i know she wouldn't wear it
she would get like really annoyed
but yeah so speaking of uh shitty movies
yeah we wanted to the other night like
friday night i was like man i'm like
tired from working i don't really want
to
you know watch anything that's too
mentally taxing i guess
and then i remembered uh to myself
that 2b has a [ __ ] ton
of roof tracks on there what are you
doing no you can watch
don't do it hi sweetie just trying to
[ __ ] rip into the t-shirts
yeah and and mystery science theater
episodes too but i've seen
those a lot of times they have like a
whole bunch of roof tracks on there that
i haven't seen yet
so i notice and they have some of the
rifftrax live shows like from the
theater which is really cool they have
the manos one which actually we went to
at the theater that was great that one
was really fun it was really the best
one live
i think i think it was i mean i've liked
all of them but
um yeah i think probably manos was the
first one
just because i'm so familiar with that
movie because i've seen it so many times
but i noticed that they had done
uh a movie called replica which was done
by the same guy
that directed erdemic james
gwen who is a vietnamese
man yeah and um i guess
okay so what ended up happening i think
this movie replica
came out before or was made before
burdemic
it was yeah it's it's not um
his first movie like he did a like a
romance movie or something called
jack and somebody or not jack can't
imagine that because something like that
because i think rifftrax did that one as
well and i think i watched it but i
didn't really remember much about it
hey but um it doesn't know much about
meeting women though
according to this well that's what i was
just gonna say it's like so this was
this was made in 2004 i think burdemic
wasn't made till 2010.
so this poor man and it's he seems like
such a nice man
but he doesn't know what's up he doesn't
know he thinks you meet women just by
following around yeah
it's all stalker behavior you just
follow a woman around and
show up at her place you know i saw you
and thought you were beautiful so i
so i'm coming to your house then they
[ __ ] call the cops on you
what the [ __ ] you doing that's what i
mean it's like does he like
not know how because i feel like that
happened in burdemic too right yeah
he doesn't come from a dating culture i
don't think maybe not because it just
seems like
because even in burdemic and in replica
the dude
and it's always because i think that um
james gwen
was is a software salesman or works in
software so that's why like all of his
characters
in these movies are like yeah corporate
software dudes yeah
he's not very western so this is just
how he's imagining how western
westerners maybe that's what it is
that's that was my takeaway from it
you just see a hot woman and you look at
her booty
and then you look at he's got part of
that right yeah she's like okay
then you just walk around with she's
walking around town and you're
following her for [ __ ] blocks
yeah and then she went home didn't she
yeah
and then he knocked on her door and he
followed her to her apartment
you will get your [ __ ] shot off by doing
that
what planet are you from i'm like you at
least get
mace and she was happy about it and then
and then the next thing you know
it's almost like porn almost happened
several times she's walking around with
damn [ __ ] stamp the porn almost broke
out it almost broke out
and the [ __ ] stamp was her own name her
own name pookie i told you i said knock
it off
okay that's it she oh that's it oh
you're in trouble
big [ __ ] trouble you're in big
[ __ ] trouble where are you going
where are you going she's like what no
stop trying to open black packages if
she sees something's wrapped
she's gonna try to open it well yeah
mail time is her favorite like when we
get packages and stuff like that she's
like ooh let pokey open
yeah so she's got this damn [ __ ] stamp
and she walks around looking proudly
just playing a trance step with her own
name and
and then she jumps on his lap and
[ __ ] goes reverse cowgirl on him
constantly every time you see him he's
[ __ ]
she's she's cut she's cowgirl in his ass
you know what's funny about that though
is that they're not even moving it's
like there's a scene where
he's laying on a couch and she's just
sitting on top of him and they're not
moving
or talking or anything and i think this
is this
is this is this dude i'm just saying
this is this dude's
interpretation of of western dating you
know that that's
their weird that's what it's like to be
a a white dude
a white dude and date white girls that's
just that you just she they just sit on
your lap
you follow them around and they sit on
your lap you follow him around and
somehow it's
charming okay right and she got a
[ __ ] trance stamp
of her own that yeah that's all right
so that was my big that was the clone
that wasn't the first woman the first
woman didn't have a [ __ ] stamp
the whole clone the whole clone angle of
this movie
was kind of lost on me none of that
[ __ ] mattered it it didn't
it didn't it didn't make any kind of
impact on you because you spent all your
time looking at these [ __ ] fake
video backgrounds yes that was another
closures
everything was like people acting and
doing a scene and you can tell
that they're in two different locations
at two different times and the scene is
a composite of two different people
yeah that are just on a fake background
yeah
and the background it's like you could
tell that
i don't know like if he just went to
some site and like downloaded some free
like backgrounds that look like a
high-tech lab or whatever
and then it's like because it was a free
trial like the
the footage was low resolution but he's
just like [ __ ] it and he decided to use
it anyway
so it's kind of like you have the actors
like composited
that green screened and like i said they
probably weren't even on the set at the
same time
and then he puts him into this
background in the background is like
super fuzzy
and it's just like it's the craziest
thing i've ever seen it's just like
i kind of feel like this like um tommy
wiseau the guy that made the room
i feel like he has a similar weird thing
where he doesn't know
how actual people like talk or act with
one another and he somehow found a bunch
of actors that are like
aliens and skin suits and it's like they
don't really interact like human beings
and it's like very very strange
but it's also it's also like really
really entertaining
like the this movie okay so the best
thing this guy i can't remember any of
the characters names except for claudia
because she had a big transducer on her
back
but um so this guy meets this girl
in the same way like he meets two girls
in this movie like in the same fashion
basically he just
no no no the first girl that he met i
can't remember the [ __ ] her name was
and um she was actually his
transplant scientist she gave him a new
kidney
yeah that was some weird [ __ ] she gave
him a new kidney they don't show that
but that happened like before the movie
started yeah and then he's kind of
low-key stalking her because it's like
he's up uh
at the san francisco like the golden
gate bridge or whatever and he sees her
jogging
and then just starts like following her
around everywhere and somehow this is
charming and not creepy and she doesn't
call the cops or like get a restraining
order or anything yeah
this guy's this guy's uh
his his what do you say his his
conception the [ __ ] dating is
stalking
i mean if a dude did this to me i would
legit be terrified
yeah it's [ __ ] that's the truth you
know it's a trip
you get the cops called on you you would
yeah
you would get kicked in the balls you
would get amazed you would have the cops
come you'd immediately be told no
just because it's just too [ __ ] weird
it's not how people meet each other yeah
it's weird stop it
so it's so yeah she was a transplant she
gave him a new kidney
and then she gets a spoiler alert by the
way
um she gets killed in the world's
slowest head-on collision and they don't
like
they don't even show it i love this
scene so much i wish somebody would make
a gif of it because i know somebody like
made a gif of like
one of the mad scientists in this like
going whoa that was like really funny
but somebody needs to make a gif of the
car accident because she backs out
of the driveway and then she's driving
and she's like la la la
i'm very pointedly not paying attention
to the road in front of me she's going
maybe five miles an hour max yeah and
then here's another car
coming this way which clearly was like
not even shot at the same time
which is also only going five miles an
hour max and then it's like
this car that car this car and then they
just cut away
there was a collision and then there was
like the cemetery
yeah and i'm like they hinted at
possibly there was a collision
a low speed collision that somehow
killed this i'm like seriously
if they as fast as these two cards are
good even if they hit each other head on
it would be like
it would be like that yeah how slow
there's a reason he didn't speed
the [ __ ] film up or the video up or
maybe he didn't think of it or
just [ __ ] lift in a [ __ ] some kind
of there wasn't even a crash phone
footage crashed
it wasn't even nothing it wasn't even
really an attempt
it was just like a smash cut to a
cemetery
and i was like yeah it wasn't even an
attempt at trying she's dead now
yeah so i guess she died and then
i couldn't really okay so i think what
happened was that she died and then
like her dna because she worked at this
like shifty
dna genetic experiment lab or whatever
and also did
transplants because i guess they grew
his kidney like in a petri dish
or something i don't know so it doesn't
matter most of this [ __ ] doesn't matter
it doesn't matter i was just waiting for
somebody to order some solar panels
solar panels solar panels solar panels
i feel like birdemic half of that movie
was
a board meeting was like yeah the
world's most boring they're trying to
sell solar panels
i guess they were it's just like a solar
panel company [ __ ] gave the money up
to make the movie maybe they did
i think so well i do you know what james
james gwen
he has wanted to make because they
actually made a sequel to burdemic
um and he wants to make a third one
which is called burdemic c eagle
which i love that i looked up on
wikipedia and he did like a kickstarter
but he only got like 500
oh i'm like what are you talking about
he could totally make that movie for
that
i mean it looks like they don't want to
see the foot they don't want to see a
sequel to bird emmick
well there was there was a sequel he's
talking about a third one
so i guess the part two was bad it was
too you know it wasn't it wasn't good
enough to generate any attention
it was great on rift tracks oh my god
when those dudes jumped out with the
[ __ ] plastic ar-15s
and were pretending to shoot the birds
and they got the [ __ ] cg muzzle
flashes that don't line up to where the
muzzles are that's fantastic they don't
even bother with any blanks
they didn't even bother fire i mean it
if you get a [ __ ] regular semi-auto
ar-15 all you gotta do is damn change
the [ __ ] muzzle break on the m they
have a blank
fire a blank firing muzzle adapter
it looks just like the real thing not
like a military
screw-on type with a big red [ __ ] or
yellow [ __ ] end
they got one looks like a birdcage flash
suppressor it's got a little bitty hole
in it and it'll allow you to fire blanks
and blanks are cheap you know you can
get them online you can get them online
back then
and you know for less than a hundred
dollars
literally for less than a hundred
dollars you could have given two or
three
m16s ah probably a little bit more about
two hundred dollars you could probably
get
three m16s probably 90 rounds of [ __ ]
blanks each and shoot them
and it would look cool you know what i
mean but real multiflex is easier
to have plastic guns and just have the
actor go like this
because they did it in this in replica
too it's ridiculous
it wasn't like i think it was just like
a pistol or whatever you don't even have
they shot they didn't have any blood or
anything it's just like you know
you don't even have to buy the guns you
can borrow them
they're common and you can borrow them
from guys that already have them or rent
them
yeah you know run them for you know they
got places where you can rent the movie
supply places that you can rent them
things i don't know what they cost but
you could low budget you could just
borrow them from friends that have them
yeah put the muzzle adapters on the end
and [ __ ]
buy some [ __ ] forty dollars worth of
bikes you know they're
[ __ ] 10 cents around 13 cents a round
sharuka dog
asks if we've seen velocipaster yes yeah
it's good very good and actually we did
a review of it a little i was i loved
philosophy yesterday i thought it was
delightful yeah it it it
perfectly nailed that cheesy 80s tone
and it knew exactly what it was
yeah and like [ __ ] the [ __ ] sports
remember the soccer game
yeah that's [ __ ] great when the dude
gets eaten in the [ __ ] camera pants
down
it was just it was so so cute i just
loved it so much
this i think the thing about this movie
this movie was also really entertaining
but this was a very different reason for
a different reason this one
seems like it's not i think the reason
that a lot of people like
the room and like birdemic and stuff
like that is because it seems like these
people
think they're making decent movies and
don't
really know what they're doing sheer
incompetence you know what i'm saying
and it's like and and just the the
weirdness of
how they think p real people interact
with one another and like just the
weirdness of the [ __ ] that they come up
with is just like so [ __ ] strange
and it's just i don't know like that
slow-motion car accident in this i just
loved it so much i just laughed and
laughed and laughed
and then like the [ __ ] hymn stock in
the first cause yes because the
girlfriend dies
in like a five mile an hour [ __ ]
crash right
and then he sees this other girl like a
[ __ ]
darker-haired version of her it's like
obviously the same actress with a wig
and sledding your clothes on
and he sees her walking down the street
and starts stalking her as well
and goes to her house and she's charmed
and everything but i think it turns out
later that she's a clone of the first
girl
but the dumb thing is is that if like
how many of these [ __ ] do they have
and what and
and i didn't know like what what did i
get out what was the
end game yeah what was the end game of
like i think he worked for some software
company and they wanted to buy
some shares of the so so maybe it was
something like that but anytime there's
and and he did this in burdemic too
where there was just so much of
this kind of like everybody sitting
around in a boardroom and being like
super excited about solar panels and
and how much they were selling and
you're just the best salesman in the
world and i was like dude i've worked in
corporate jobs i don't need to see a
movie about everybody sitting around in
a [ __ ] boardroom it's really really
boring
yeah so it's like i don't want to see it
in a movie yeah and what they're doing
in those boardrooms fake anyway
that's just you know it's like
none of that it's on the white board
none of that shit's gonna happen none of
that shit's really gonna happen it's
gonna fail
and sales are not gonna [ __ ] be up to
stuff they know well that's what i mean
and it just seems like i don't know i
always like
it's just like hubbard's ex constant
[ __ ] growth exponential it just
always seemed like that to me and just
it seemed like every time you'd go to a
meeting
yeah it was just nothing would ever get
accomplished like everyone's just in
there like is when is this going to be
yeah they're just going through the
motions because that's what the higher
ups told you to do get them in a board
room get them fired up get it get it go
get themselves some [ __ ] this isn't it
like great can i just get back to my
[ __ ] work now yeah because i'm just
like a year later the [ __ ] companies
the company's disintegrated and no
longer exists anyway it doesn't matter i
told you that when i used to work for
the scientologist
if your [ __ ] stats weren't up from
last week every single week
your [ __ ] yeah yeah they had a meeting
every single morning
and like it was so so funny it was just
like
like i said it was like the two minutes
hate or it was kind of like you know the
name and shame kind of thing yeah it's
like
you'd come in and if your [ __ ] was down
everybody be like
look at you like it's like the
self-criticism communist self-criticism
[ __ ] hour
but if you were up then everybody would
clap yeah see what you do is you just
lie that you're up
well that's what i did that's what
they're doing i think that's what most
people do yeah
because i'm like well why wouldn't you
yeah it's not like they're going to
[ __ ] do that
i'm going to check oh i'm up yeah okay
yeah we're well they're just going
through the momentum yeah everyone
clapped
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah all right
let's go give me my [ __ ] paycheck
it's like selling am way
holy crap it's like you have to put up
with so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
to make a [ __ ] honest day's waiting
i'm glad that those cult that cultures
that culture is [ __ ] gone
it's like i please just do my job and
make my money i
really don't want any of this other
frippery that goes along with it i hate
it
all those big all those big businesses
that had offices in downtown uh
new york have found out that they're
making more money getting more
productivity
and making more profit without having
people just having people stay at home
wow you know like i said most people
they just work better at home
are yeah i mean i can see how some
people at home especially if you have
kids and [ __ ] like that like it could be
a pain yes there are a lot of
distractions and [ __ ] like that
but you know i think 95 percent of
people if you let them work at home they
will get the [ __ ]
done i mean it's not like everyone's
just gonna like sit around eating
cheetos on the couch or whatever it's
like people need money
they wanna there are people writing
articles that they that they worked
downtown in new york just [ __ ] a
couple weeks ago they said [ __ ] it they
moved out and they're all living in
arizona now working from home living
like kings
saying that they're glad they're out of
the city but they work at that same
place it's just
you know telecommuting every [ __ ] day
like i said a lot of jobs you don't
really need
to physically be there you don't need
somebody like breathing down your neck
all the time to make sure you're doing
[ __ ] as long as the shit's getting
done i don't really see the need i think
it's great and like i said now that they
have zoom and [ __ ] like that if you
absolutely must have a [ __ ] meeting
everybody can just have them from their
own house you don't have to be there
it's
dumb i'm just it's a waste of time
it's a waste of [ __ ] construction
materials and energy and [ __ ]
resources to have those big old [ __ ]
office buildings there
it's a [ __ ] waste yeah well that's
yeah
that's just obsolete technology well
like i said nowadays we have the
internet we can do
pretty much everything from the house so
it's like if if you can do that i know
that there are some jobs that can't be
uh done that way which obviously but if
you can do it that way why not a lot of
that shit's obsolete they they're even
those companies are changing hiring
practices they realize that well
everybody
pretty much everybody can use it com
everybody knows how to use a computer
now we don't really care if you go to
colleges
if you've been to college as long as you
can use this computer to get the work
done we'll hire you
they're doing that now yeah because it
doesn't matter well
if you know how to do this you know how
to do it then it doesn't matter they
don't care i mean like i said i'm glad i
went to college but um
a lot of stuff i just had to teach
myself later
later on right you know which everybody
has to do i mean they can't teach you
every single thing
you have to learn a lot of [ __ ] on the
job i went for two semesters got out of
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] it like i said it depends on what
you're studying i was doing that
accounting and that [ __ ] i i
would admit a shitty accountant
you would have a shitty account i just
that's it's boring boring boring my mom
did that for a while
and when i became a salesman that was a
lot better for me a lot more well that's
like a lot more
more attuned to your personality yeah
not mine i don't like it but that's all
gone now i worked in retail like
briefly like in the early 90s and i
hated it i was doing direct sales i love
because i hate the public i
i did real well it's direct sales and
[ __ ] um but
that era is over now everything's online
it just doesn't make sense to be out
there if i can pound it on doors
like i said see trying to talk for the
win
yeah now but he's got to adapt to my
[ __ ] lifestyle
if i wanted to i bet you i could just
make a [ __ ] ton of money on a damn on a
damn
um ebay store go for it i probably could
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] buying junk you see and go
that'll sell and put that [ __ ] up on
ebay
a lot of people do that a lot of people
do it yeah my brother used to do
something like that
i got it she got a [ __ ] here
he goes to estate sales and buys [ __ ]
for like he buys like whole like um
storage units of like just
yeah we're really cheap it's like people
that have died and whatever or that it's
been repo'd and then he just resolved it
yeah so make a lot of money yeah he does
that and
uh and his wife is um a medical
transcription ebay has changed the game
yeah so they both work online as well
and have for many many years they've
both worked at home yeah
so we we're into it but i had all the
middlemen
yeah but yeah so if you want to
watch i believe that toby
has all of it has burdemic
and replica and um
jack and somebody said it up there now i
can't remember the
the other name but the the three movies
that this guy has made
and it has like the ref the riptrax
version of those it might actually have
the regular burdemic version and the
rifftrax live version the one that we
went to the theater to see i think
that's on there as well because
sometimes they'll do
like a regular rifftrax version that was
like them in the studio
but then sometimes they'll do like a
live one too so sometimes and they do
like completely different
jokes these i mean the three of them
because you know anybody that watches
the shows like knows i'm a huge mystery
science theater fan
and i love that everybody
from that has kind of like gone on to do
similar things and have been like
successful at it
rifftrax i can't believe how many
[ __ ] movies they've done i mean it
just blows my [ __ ] mind they must
just work
all the time because if there's just
zillions of them there's a whole bunch
of them for free that you can get on
tubey
um you know they have a whole website
they do shorts they do all kind of [ __ ]
you can buy the shorts for like 99 cents
they're fantastic
um i have like a [ __ ] ton of them like
on my old computer
that i watch but it's just and sometimes
they'll do the same movie like multiple
times and they write a whole new jokes
every single time that they do it it's
like i don't even know how they have the
patience
to like sit through the same movie
comments and questions somebody asked
julian jack thank you that's what it's
called
somebody asked me what was btk's opinion
on global warming
uh [ __ ] where's btk btk is a better
he's back there but i can channel him
remotely
[Laughter]
gotta understand something about global
warming and
how how the weather works
it gets hot you know it gets hot
sometimes and
it's because there's too many people and
it gets too hot and
i was doing the right thing by bringing
a number of people down it's cooling it
down
cold it cooled it down a little bit
yeah where every person i killed it
actually reduced to the temperature
so yeah that's an interesting way of
looking yeah so you know btk would say
global warming is a reality all right
okay and he was trying to solve a
problem okay
um all right uh gee thanks dennis yeah
he's a good man you're a hero he's a
good man okay
uh yeah tubia is pretty cool it has some
really random stuff it really i'm
i think um [ __ ] i guess dimitri told
me about it like a year or two ago and i
had never heard of it
but they have a [ __ ] ton of stuff
i mean it's just like incredible what
you come across they have like a
zillion horror movies and they have a
lot of shitty ones but they have a lot
of really good ones too and a lot of
like early classics
you just you know it's a lot to wade
through but they you know they have
documentaries they have tv series they
have
all kind of [ __ ] it's like i could
happily it's been just
have the rest of my life and watch [ __ ]
on there because
i was scrolling through there the other
day and there was i was like holy crap
they have this movie oh my god they have
this movie oh my god they have this
movie they have like a lot of really
weird like cult classics and
obscure [ __ ] and it's pretty awesome um
and you can watch them for free
sharokina dog is saying now they could
use those uh
office buildings for apartments and um
i'm gonna put those uh
actually i disagree with that
those office buildings are inefficient
even for apartments it'd be like uh
it's kind of going the way of [ __ ]
malls
all right some people were saying that
maybe you could take these dead malls
and turn them into apartments and uh
use them you know what i mean for
something it's just not the way
structures are built especially malls
the constructions weren't that good
well it depends on when it was built
yeah a lot of them were older i mean if
it's new
then yeah they could they could reuse it
but if it's old i would imagine they
looked like i don't start over i looked
into it though and there's
there's a lot more a lot more problems
involved with
converting things or re repurposing
things
malls had flat roofs and those roofs
tended to [ __ ] have a lot of problems
over time
also where they were located the real
estate in which they were located
actually is not ideal for housing um
they were ideal for a commercial
situation and a lot of times a
commercial situation
in the past so it's not really worth it
because
you turn the thing into some kind of
apartment complex but it's also now
in a food desert in an area where
there's no employment
so it doesn't work out that easily you
know what i mean
um you might be able to convert it into
apartments but
quickly the value of the apartments
would decline and it would kind of
ghettoize and destroy itself so
it's just not worth it it's better to
just tear it down and sell the property
uh for like a new purpose that fits its
its location it's the same thing with
those office buildings
where they're located a lot of times is
in a city that
is no longer [ __ ]
no longer technologically viable you
know
cities happened in the first place
because a long time ago you needed
centralized
command over things like production and
banking and
so everybody had to merge together
in one area to get some kind of job done
well all that can be done
remotely over the internet now so
the purpose of a lot of those cities is
starting to fade away
you're seeing that now they're just
that type of construction i'm talking
about a city itself
big metropolitan cities are becoming
obsolete
anything that you can do in the city you
can also do in the country
if you got an internet connection yeah
so
some people might say well that's a bad
thing not really quality of life in
some of those big cities it's not that
good it'd probably be better
even even with ecology to kind of spread
out
uh and uh kind of live in a lower
density population
you know probably a lot easier on
ecology
because uh a city just [ __ ] sucks a
place [ __ ] dry it's not efficient
not efficient at all a lot of energy
wasted in maintaining the city
but because it's big structures they
require a lot of
power to run them and a lot of money and
energy to
to maintain giant structures like that
they're just not
ideal anymore we've seen like on
some of the dead mall um channels
that some malls they have actually put
offices
into the mall yeah you know what i mean
which seems to be like working out okay
but
like i said it all depends on what the
location is on location
um you know so at least some of the mall
is getting used because like they like
moved some offices and [ __ ] into there
because the rent was cheap
yeah but that's all a temporary
situation yeah usually what's in there
is things like a dmv
yeah or something that's kind of
state-backed or government-backed maybe
like a doctor's office they might put
that in there
but what uh what a mall was originally
was kind of a crazy idea it was downtown
with a roof on it
so you can walk around in a downtown and
air conditioning yeah
so a lot of the problem is air
conditioning all right it's a lot of
energy to air condition the open spaces
in between all those things
it's a lot better to have a downtown
area
with separate stores
outside with their own air conditioning
yeah all right it's a lot more efficient
um also it doesn't attract [ __ ]
hoodlums and stuff where you just got
vagrants in the air conditioning
uh those vagrants kind of usually
teenagers
chase away all the business all right
uh because they you know the older
people feel unsafe you know
and uh that's that's that's another one
of the problems you take that roof away
the vagrancy goes away so the businesses
actually do better
the markets changed what they were
thinking of in a time
that those countries started to mollify
is they were trying they were basically
kind of thinking what you saw in logan's
run where
everybody lived in a public square that
was indoors
you know and that worked for a while go
back and look at old videos of malls in
the 70s man they were
[ __ ] booming well yeah i mean that's
where everybody was i mean the 70s and
80s they
built so many yeah which was one of the
reasons why
uh so many of them are closing out is
because they're they over mauled
i mean they built so many clothes
together and they just couldn't sustain
yeah they couldn't they they devoured
one another yeah
uh but it was also a lot
they were a lot more successful in those
in that older culture
because it was a new and fresh idea
air conditioning was kind of a new
concept too i mean it had been around
but it hadn't been around all that much
and the idea that you could be indoors
in a futuristic environment
you know [ __ ] with neon lights and
air conditioning and music playing and
everything that you could buy was at
your fingertips you know you could get a
pretzel or a burrito and you could go
get a [ __ ] shirt
and you felt lucky they may even have
like
an aladdin's castle [ __ ] video arcade
in there you were like the [ __ ]
you go there now and you go to a mall
and all you do is just see a limited
selection you're like
[ __ ] i can get this [ __ ] off of
amazon cheaper and a better better
selection
because the internet [ __ ] gives you
access to all the products
and a lot more competitive prices well
and the thing about it too is that i
feel like in the 70s and 80s before we
had the internet before i mean that was
a place where teenagers whereas you
could go and hang out you weren't old
enough to go to clubs or bars
and it's like it was a place you could
go you could get something to eat you
could hang out there all day
that was the medium mostly stay out of
trouble that was social media yes the
mall
yeah because they didn't have you have
internet yeah and you didn't have like
[ __ ] to do in your house
really so it was like someplace to just
go and hang out with your friends
what they did around here it was funny
what they did with the mall
mall we used to go to is they decided to
do kind of like this agenda 21 thing
where you connected all the little malls
and everything with walkways and paths
and then you had near the malls kind of
lower income housing so they could
shop at the mall and not have to [ __ ]
drive in a car they could walk over to
the mall
it made a lot of sense every time we
went there you know i mean they were
eating out of the food court food court
was packed remember that
yeah the food court was always full and
you could tell you know what i mean
that you know that the mall near us was
actually usually pretty crowded it was
usually pretty crowded
and and almost all the stores were
occupied
yeah they weren't empty but not the
anchors that's the weird thing
every one of the two of the anchors had
closed because they went out of business
on a national level
and then the other two that were still
there were in danger of closing
now they're probably closed yeah i think
the dillards was still open but it
needed some work like on the roof and
stuff
and and then another attraction to it
right outside the other outside the mall
was the emc
that's closed now so
the typical pattern is with malls i've
studied this [ __ ]
okay because i was just totally [ __ ]
totally [ __ ] um uh fascinated
with the death of [ __ ] malls because
they were a part of our culture
our our generation kind of had a a foot
in the old world and the new world we
saw all this [ __ ] happen
as soon as those anchor stores are gone
the mall [ __ ] collapses
because the anchor stores are the ones
that made that that were the big
rent payers to the mall they were the
ones that were paying for the upkeep and
the air conditioning
as soon as the anchor stores are gone
the [ __ ] air conditioning is
basically gone
it kind of goes into one of these things
where like bank receiver ship where the
bank might own it and they might let it
run as a zombie mall for a while try to
sell it
but there's so many zombie malls that
banks are trying to get rid of that
they're
nobody's interested in them they just
get torn down and that that's what will
happen to them all
well yeah like i said if you go on dan
bell's channel it's like
he usually goes to like a lot of ones
and he gets to one sometimes too before
right before they get torn down it's
weird to walk through some [ __ ] like
that the [ __ ] is giant it's like
something out of damn star destroyer and
in [ __ ]
in in [ __ ] star wars you're like
nothing this big could fail and that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] failing
and you could walk into one of the
anchor stores and you smell bad mold
because the roof's leaking and they
don't have the money to fix it
and it's just you think that something
like that would last forever but you can
just sense the sense of decay
you can sense the decay setting in
to in the old world it's going to vanish
and but it's going to be replaced with
this [ __ ] that's more efficient
that makes more sense in the modern
world yeah i mean
it just makes sense that's just how it
goes it's like i know people get bummed
out about it but it's just kind of like
i mean [ __ ] might get better you don't
know it's like
what's happening is everything is
migrating to your house
yeah everything that those things can be
can do can be done at your house
uh drones will come and deliver your
shopping at your house
you know all the stores are on your
tablet
all the movies are on your [ __ ] smart
tv
so you end up you're going to end up
being in a goddamn bubble in a certain
way to where you can live an entire full
life your work and everything right
leaving your [ __ ] house that's like
some [ __ ] out i mean you can if you want
to but you don't have to
eventually that's what it's going to do
that's where the market's going to go
it's going to be like something out of
the matrix
you're going to wake up and find out
you're in a tub a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we're all right with that everything is
now happening in your mind
you don't have to leave the vat you know
what i mean that's the
that's eventually what what we're
talking about here come feedback and
then your vet
your body he runs the vat and [ __ ]
runs the [ __ ] virtual matrix that
you're in
that's very efficient very very
efficient but that's kind of what
they're talking about
so in this new brave new world that
we're that we're heading towards
shopping and your daily [ __ ] [ __ ] is
no longer going to be a big part of your
life in terms of wasting time
the future is going to be about going
and going to clubs and going to social
events and [ __ ] on the outside
everything else can be done in the house
which like i said i'm totally fine i'm
good with that it's just that because
we remember jenny and i came from an age
where [ __ ] maybe once a week
four or five hours of that week was
spent driving around town
[ __ ] cashing checks and paying
[ __ ] bills yeah when's the last time
you had to do that yeah
you used to have to go to a place to pay
bills to pay your [ __ ] bill you
burn gasoline driving your [ __ ] car
to pay bills
to pay like then you have to check then
you had to pay for the car and pay for
the gasoline to go and to get to work to
pay for your bills
it was a crazy ass [ __ ] way of doing
it you
you spent a lot of money just to keep
the [ __ ] stupid system going of
driving around paying bills
yeah you know i mean that was a little
past my time because i remember my
grandmother and my parents having to do
that
um but i never had to go anywhere to pay
bills
now i do remember i do remember having
to write checks
and put them through the actual mail i
remember doing that
but i don't think i remember ever having
to like once i moved out on my own i
don't think i ever had to go anywhere
like other than going to like you know
drop off a rent check or something like
that like at the place yeah i never had
stamps and envelopes and [ __ ] like that
you know what i mean so i just run down
to the [ __ ]
uh like office of [ __ ] my landlord's
office and [ __ ] write a check and
give a check
yeah you know what i mean or maybe i i
[ __ ] dreaded [ __ ] paying the damn
phone bill
you had to fill out the [ __ ] check
you know what i mean and then
sent a letter to the [ __ ] phone
company and she had to be
sent on time i was like man come on man
i'm [ __ ] 20. i don't need to be doing
this [ __ ]
man i was like this is like old people
[ __ ]
yeah well i remember my i remember my
grandmother i think for a time like you
could go
to like certain malls and stuff like
that and they had a place where you just
like you know florida power and light or
whatever and they would like you could
go there and pay your electric balance
yeah
and she had to go like to jcpenney for
example
and pay like her jcpenney credit card
bill you had to like go there and pay it
which is crazy i remember that when i
was a kid yeah like she had a good
paypals but yeah
insane um i remember the days before
cash machines yeah i do too
it's like [ __ ] it's just crazy it's
crazy how much easier everything is
nowadays
it's why i try not to like whine about
too much stuff because
everything back in the day was like so
[ __ ] hard and it's like you had to
like [ __ ]
go place and i hate driving i hate
commuting i hate all that kind of [ __ ]
so i'm just
the more [ __ ] i can do myself from my
own house like the happier i am
seriously and the less people i have to
deal with
also like out in the world sugar can i
get the pressures from the cities will
go down yeah
the need for a city is going down people
are if you look at right now the news
those big northern cities the rents are
falling because a lot of them are
leaving
california everybody all my family's
gone from california now wes my aunt
wesley and lois my cousin lois they're
leaving
they're going to be going to uh virginia
i think it is
it's just the quality of life isn't very
good you pay a lot of [ __ ] money real
high taxes and you just live in poverty
so there's no advantage to living there
anymore
used to be when i lived in california
what was so cool about it is that
back in the 70s and in the early 80s
that state was ahead of the rest of the
country
you could get sushi that was a big
[ __ ] deal nobody else has sushi
yeah that was like it's it's funny to
think about now because now you can get
it everywhere you get that [ __ ]
everywhere
uh you could [ __ ] go and and see
things and well all the everything that
california used to have
that made it different from the rest of
the [ __ ] country
can be found in mississippi now yeah
yeah it's just everything proliferated
yeah so it's like it's not
it doesn't have that special you don't
have to be there anymore
it's just another place and uh and it's
too expensive
so uh and it's miserable i mean there's
like a resurgence of [ __ ] medieval
diseases and [ __ ]
like typhus happening and and [ __ ]
it's tax base all the people that were
paying the taxes are leaving so they're
kind of going to these death spirals
new york city's in a death spiral all
the all the people that were paying the
taxes are leaving
you know mayor cuomo is going to come
back i'll make you a dinner like nah
that's going to go the way of detroit
and it happened in detroit in a very
short period of time detroit never
recovered
and uh living in detroit and see what
that's like
detroit's mostly gone it's just damn
open fields and gardens there's
it's returned to nature and that's why
i'm saying that
turning office buildings back into
apartment buildings that didn't work in
detroit those office buildings are gone
there's just empty fields there now
because it's the location there's no
reason to live there
there's no jobs yeah so you can't rent
it out
you could go into have a huge skyscraper
for yourself like something out of
[ __ ] blade runner
you know what i mean but you couldn't
maintain it because you can't work there
yeah there's no jobs looks like
out in the middle of siberia there's
probably big-ass [ __ ] whole abandoned
cities
towns and [ __ ] tankelgrad or whatever
from the cold world war but you can't
live there there's nothing there
yeah there's no people there so it's
that's what eventually happens
uh it's not worth it to keep a big
building like that going
and turned into apartments you just
can't generate enough from rents to keep
it going it's just it's not efficient
yeah but uh so just the way of the world
things change
technology change they don't make big
pyramids anymore
it's not efficient you don't need to
send the king to the [ __ ]
orion's bill okay they don't it took a
long time to build a pyramid they didn't
do much
and it's going to be the same way with
these [ __ ] big mega cities they just
they're not really worth it you just
sending the king up to orion's belt yeah
i'm going to send a [ __ ] king to a
ryan's toes
there it is they had shafts so the king
could see which star it was so his soul
could
so he could
[Laughter]
into the [ __ ] heavenly procession of
the [ __ ]
souls in space and [ __ ] you know the
egyptians had a cool way of looking at
[ __ ] space
now i kind of want my now i kind of want
my ashes put into a t-shirt cannon
inside
that'd be funny as [ __ ] like off they go
all right so we've been going on for
almost an hour
yeah it's time for us i'm sure like
people are probably sick of looking at
us like we were almost five hours last
night then we're like [ __ ] yakking
again
yeah holy [ __ ] all right so uh we'll
probably stream again tomorrow at three
o'clock um
i'll probably find a new movie to watch
so we'll probably
talk about a movie if not we'll think of
something else to talk about because
clearly we don't really need to have
anything to talk about because we just
started talking and
yeah you know it and you're that's what
we'll see that's all right that's all
right
uh but yeah so uh we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow so have a good
rest of your weekend bye